je suis extrêmement choquée puisqu'on a
atteint on a fait atteinte aux valeurs
de la république et surtout parce que je
suis extrêmement en colère
extrêmement en colère parce que je pense
qu'on paye quand même des années de
laxisme et qu'il est temps que nos
politiques fassent quelque chose pour
nous protéger mais je disais à double
titre parce que mon fils est et au
commissariat de mantes la jolie en poste
donc collègues de jessica l'îlot dans la
tête ils sont plus à l'abri quoi je le
pense surtout à cet enfant de trois ans
qui se retrouvent orphelins c'est très
triste
ça pourrait arriver à n'importe qui j'ai
l'impression qu'on est plus en sécurité
ici